I also want to say this to you Sam um
you know when I'm in New York you're
you're the out of all the New York
Comics you're the nicest to me am I an
Comics not nice to you they're not nice
I mean they're not mean it's just your
you have an energy of like welcome to my
home oh yeah let's hang out or how are
you you know I mean like that kind of
vibe where it's like with all the other
guys there's nice but it's like they're
not like welcome you know it's almost as
if I'm like maybe in their Turf it feels
like you know I mean we like having you
there man I love when I see it the
seller and stuff yeah but it was so nice
you and Rachel Feinstein one of my best
friends he's the best yeah no you're uh
we're happy to see you always but you
guys were so comforting and um you know
it's like I understand why you love it
out there really would you ever move to
New York
why not never
I'll tell you why because
um I've never like you know we're broken
up but I've never ever hooked up with a
girl in New York when you're there for
three days no but I've been there so
many times in my life yeah but a week at
a time you're not there long yeah oh it
takes a month if I get [__] in [__]
New York I think so I mean that's a
horrible thing it's a it takes a month
to date anybody in New York there we go
that was better yeah so you uh
what do you uh what's the procedure here
how do you make it happen here
I I just feel like can read them better
in terms of like
um if they like me or not I opposite
thing like I can't tell guys in La for
me are just like immediately like I
can't my body can't do it but when I was
in New York well you've had the best you
know what I'm saying but when I was in
New York
[Laughter]
um yeah but opposite I think New York's
so fun people I feel like they're nicer
there I feel like everything is just
you're a hot chick
you're a catch Bobby exactly oh really I
think you're a catch I I don't know I
don't know because I just went on tour
and you know Carlos you know I mean he's
getting a lot of play out there Carlos
would want and I got no I got nothing I
think Carlos would want to announce that
and have you believe that but I don't
think you're trying as hard as Carl no
I've seen him walk down to the lobby
with a new girl every city but you've
also announced that you're celibate yeah
but that's just my game play well that's
a that's a it's not work
I feel like it's not working I I don't
[__] why won't women [__] me they only
announced on a podcast that I'm celibate
I don't understand no because I don't
want people to think that I'm like
sleeping around so I I say sellable well
mission accomplished
no dude say stop saying that I'm selling
I'm open you're open you're back in
you're back in the market well can I
tell you why you're adorable dude thank
you you are I think you're very cute man
yeah Sean O'Malley goes I just want to
cuddle him yeah that's what he said yeah
I'm cuddable but that's not anyway you
know what I'll you'll see I'm gonna look
like Jet Li in a year let's go we're
gonna
are you a fitness guy no but I've been
I've been exercising really good I I
mean I had I drink enough that if I
don't exercise I will look like [__] so
I have to do something you don't seem
like you have any muscle yeah it's a
problem no no but you can get them yeah
you can I could yeah yeah she's a thin
God do you not eat I eat a lot and
Norman's thin yeah we we just exercise a
lot I like do a lot of cardio because I
just want the Boost I want the boost on
the road oh so you you run
I'll do stuff like that or I uh yeah I
just uh I'm not a huge weight I do a
little I feel like I'm not my body's
been described as a holocaust body so
like that's what they don't have that
option on dating apps yeah do I just go
with Athletics yeah but uh no I uh
like when you look in the mirror naked
you go uh Holocaust
sometimes so it's me like you're weak
I'm all right yeah yeah you feel seem
healthy to me really yeah it looked weak
I know but I mean compared to like Joe
Rogan yeah yeah are we comparing
ourselves to Joe Rogan right now
I do you know what I mean when you look
in the mirror what do you tell yourself
what do you say yeah well you know I've
been eating a lot of fat
what kind like Twinkies and stuff okay
oh it's on the road you know because we
don't winkies well you know we you go to
truck stops sure when you're on a tour
bus and I'll go oh yeah they have
healthy options at truck stops they do
nuts and stuff